>>> DAVID, FOR THE LAST TIME,
YOU HAVE TO UNPACK YOUR CLOTHES.
WE MOVED IN A MONTH AGO, HONEY.
>> I WILL, MOM.
I HAVE JUST BEEN BUSY.
>> BUSY FLIRTING WITH EVERY GIRL
IN SCHOOL.
>> SHUT UP.
>> HONEY, IS EVERYTHING OKAY?
>> I JUST FOUND THIS LETTER
SLIPPED UNDER OUR DOOR.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S STRANGE.
>> WHAT DOES IT SAY?
>> DEAREST NEW NEIGHBORS AT 322
OAK RIDGE BOULEVARD, ALLOW ME TO
INTRODUCE MYSELF.
I AM THE LOOKER, AND I SEE
EVERYTHING YOU DO.
>> IS THIS SOME KIND OF SICK
PRANK?
>> I DON'T KNOW, CAROL.
>> I SEE YOU'RE SETTLING IN
NICELY.
YOUR DAUGHTER LIKES TO WRITE IN
HER DIARY ABOUT THE BOY WHO MOES
THE LAWN, AND YOUR SON HAS BEEN
HARD AT WORK PRACTICING HIS
GUITAR.
>> THIS IS CREEPING ME OUT.
>> AND YOUR WIFE, AFTER
EVERYONE'S ASLEEP, SHE GOES TO
THE KITCHEN AND EATS AN ENTIRE
SECOND DINNER.
>> THAT'S LIKE -- WHAT?
>> SHE EATS IT LIKE A GREEDY
RACCOON AFRAID OF GETTING
CAUGHT.
>> OKAY.
>> AS FOR YOU, DADDY DEAREST.
I HOPE YOU ENJOY YOUR MORNING
JOGS AROUND THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
I KNOW YOUR WIFE DOES.
AFTER YOU LEAVE, SHE GETS A
SNACK, TURNS ON THE TV, AND
PLEASURES HERSELF.
TO THE PROPERTY BROTHERS.
>> OKAY.
THAT'S NOT RINGING A BELL.
>> BUT HE KNOWS ABOUT MY JOGS,
CAROL.
>> AND MY DIARY AND DAVID'S
GUITAR.
>> I KNOW.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO WEIRD THAT
ALL MY STUFF IS CLEARLY MADE UP.
>> YOUR LIFE MAY SEEM PERFECT,
BUT THE LOOKER KNOWS IT'S NOT,
AND YOUR POOR WIFE SEEMS TO BE
HAVING TROUBLE IN THE BATHROOM.
SLOWLY ROCKING BACK AND FORTH,
TRYING TO MAKE SOMETHING HAPPEN.
GIVING HERSELF PEP TALKS.
>> COME ON, COME ON.
>> SHE GETS SO FRUSTRATED SHE'LL
GO DOWNSTAIRS AND BLOW OFF MORE
STEAM WITH PROPERTY BROTHERS.
WHY IS SHE SO AROUSED BY THAT
SHOW?
IS IT THE BROTHERS OR THE
PROPERTY?
>> SOMEONE DOWNLOADED EVERY
EPISODE OF PROPERTY BROTHERS.
>> AND WATCHED FIVE MINUTES OF
EACH ONE.
>> SO THIS WEIRDO SNUCK INTO OUR
HOUSE AND MESSED WITH THE TV?
NOW I'M WEIRDED OUT OFFICIALLY.
>> THEN SHE SAYS, TIKTOK DANCES,
YOUR MOM WAS ON HER EXERCISE
BIKE.
>> THAT ONE'S REAL!
>> SHE DOESN'T EVEN PEDAL.
JUST SITS ON THE BIKE AND LOOKS
AT HER PHONE.
THEN GOES BACK TO THE BATHROOM
TO TRY AGAIN.
>> WHY CAN'T I GO!
>> WE NEED TO GO TO THE POLICE
AND TELL THEM THIS GUY IS MAKING
UP LIES ABOUT JUST ME.
>> WE WILL.
I THINK IT WILL BE SAFEST IF WE
STAY IN THE HOTEL TONIGHT.
>> ONE OF US SHOULD STAY.
I GUESS I'LL DO IT SINCE THIS
GUY'S GOT NOTHING ON ME.
>> IT'S DEMO DAY.
>> IF YOU'RE WATCHING, IT'S THE
PROPERTY I'M INTO.
NOT THE BROTHERS.